this armored vehicle will be used
strictly for defensive purposes there's
no offensive capabilities at all with
our vehicle a strictly defensive vehicle
used to protect our officers in the
worst of the worst situations utilized
to to protect citizens that you know as
needed and officers as well that are in
harm's way an immediate imminent harm's
way well we don't expect to face any
threats such as mines here in central
Indiana there's the potential we could
face significant other threats from an
improvised explosive devices that has
occurred here right here in these United
States
those are frequently specifically
targeted at first responders these can
help keep our first responders safe our
philosophy is we'd rather have a vehicle
of this capabilities and hope that we
never need it rather than need it and
not have it not have that capability
plus if we were to purchase this on the
open market it'd be anywhere from a
quarter of a million dollars upwards of
a half a million dollars to purchase a
vehicle with this capabilities we got
this one for a grand total sixty two
hundred dollars